there's a lot to digest in zack snyder's
justice league from the appearance of
martian manhunter
to lois lane's pregnancy test revelation
however there is one thing that almost
instantly became very clear from this
version of the movie
as compared to the original one finished
by joss whedon
and released in 2017 when the woman gets
her gym
sci-fi wire noted that diana became a
lame rom-com protagonist
nagging bickering and flirting with
batman despite the way he shoehorned
steve trevor into a conversation
to get an emotional reaction out of her
she became victim to gratuitous upskirt
shots hunter action scenes oddly
but truncated sci-fi wires said one of
her action scenes
also seemed clearly like a weed and
reshoot created for fan service
as it has zero to do with the wider plot
thanks to the snyder cut though
that view of wonder woman is gone she
now claims a front and center position
in the justice league's battle against
steppenwolf
showing that she was leading with her
trademark compassion and care the whole
time so
let's really get into that scene when
wonder woman battles steppenwolf and
cuts off his head
the scene takes place in part 7 the
final confrontation between the heroes
and darkseid's minion
while every one of the heroes
participates in the standoff cyborg and
the flash's specialized abilities
mean they can focus on making sure the
unity never happens
the plan is for flash to whip up a
charge that will allow cyborg to disrupt
the synchronization
of the mother boxes the others batman
aquaman and wonder woman
are left to deal with a steppenwolf who
seems especially to enjoy taunting diana
telling her she abandoned her sisters
and bringing up her mother's death
superman soon enters the fray helping
both groups
when the plan fails the flash turns back
time to give everyone a second chance
in the end the superman takes off
steppenwolf's horn and aquaman spears
him
but it's diana who gets in the killing
blow as superman pushes the alien menace
back toward the portal
that will bring him back to dark side
diana jumps in with a sword slicing his
head off just before he enters the boom
tube
this was the intended ending to justice
league all along
and it's one of the reasons that fans
are loving this restored version of the
character
one user posted on twitter this is
easily the best movie that has ever been
made
about wonder woman her personality
culture family
ability strength wisdom etc she carries
the action in the film
and they give her a ton of screen time
to showcase her power
in a way i've never seen anyone do
before a scene allows diana to exhibit
her fierceness and boldness as a warrior
removing any doubt about her abilities
and bringing back a vision of the
character that should have never been
allowed to lapse as it did in the
original justice league there's no doubt
that steppenwolf is a powerful foe
requiring the combined efforts of heroes
like superman and the wonder woman
despite their own formidable strengths
in dc comics canon steppenwolf is a new
god
diana is a demigod her father was zeus
and her mother was hippolyta of the
amazons
in this way they are equals this means
that to director zack snyder wonder
woman killing steppenwolf is basically
the only ending that makes any sense by
definition gods can't be killed
at least not by mere mortals even ones
with mutant powers like aquaman or ones
who get theirs from the yellow sun like
superman
in 2019 snyder made a post on vero that
revealed his concept of that climactic
scene in three unfinished images
in the caption he noted not sure how
they killed steppenwolf in the
theatrical version of justice
league this was never finished all the
way but i used gods to kill gods
it turns out snyder's idea of wonder
woman seems so reasonable
that it's the one many others are
embracing too
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc
eu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one